in this lesson we'll look at the
mechanisms for the payoff phase of
glycolysis
the last five steps in which net atp is
produced if you're looking for the
mechanisms of any of the reactions in
the energy investment phase of
glycolysis those are in part one and you
can check out that video all right let's
look at some mechanisms
in the sixth step of glycolysis
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate is converted
to 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate
the enzyme that catalyzes this reaction
is glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase and that name
along with the fact that the coenzyme
nad plus is involved
lets us know that this enzyme is an
oxidoreductase we're going to see some
redox chemistry an active site cysteine
and a histidine are our catalytic
residues
acting as a base histidine will
deprotonate the thiol of cysteine and a
lone pair on sulfur can attack this
carbon
in a carbonyl addition reaction
the arrow pushing looks like this
the lone pair on nitrogen attacks the
hydrogen and we can show the hydrogen
sulfur bond forming a bond to this
carbon
as we push the electrons from the double
bond up onto oxygen this gives an
intermediate that's covalently bound to
the enzyme now the coenzyme nad plus
which is bound to the enzyme through
weak interactions can come into play
notice the positively charged nitrogen
in the aromatic ring this allows for
bonds to break that we usually wouldn't
think about breaking like we saw in step
four with the iminium ion promoting the
cleavage of a carbon-carbon bond now
we're going to see cleavage of a carbon
hydrogen bond to facilitate this a base
will deprotonate here
allowing electrons to form a carbonyl
and that will push hydrogen off with its
electrons
our base deprotonates this hydrogen the
electrons form a carbonyl and hydride a
hydrogen with its electrons can reduce
nad plus
attack on the ring occurs exactly
opposite the positively charged nitrogen
and we can use the electrons in the
conjugated system to neutralize the
positive charge nad plus is aromatic but
charged and the reduced form nadh
is neutral but
non-aromatic because of this sp3
hybridized carbon right here the other
product that we form from this part is
going to be an enzyme-bound thioester
thioesters are reactive intermediates
that can undergo nucleophilic acyl
substitution
so in this case
we're going to have a molecule of
inorganic phosphate enter the active
site this isn't a high energy phosphate
compound like atp is but when we
substitute this phosphate for this
sulfur
we're going to get bpg
which has even higher phosphoryl
transfer ability than atp
nucleophilic acyl substitution is an
addition elimination mechanism so first
we'll use the negative charge on our
phosphate to attack the carbonyl the
electrons push onto oxygen and we get
this intermediate notice the phosphate
group loses its proton after the attack
at physiological ph phosphate groups
ionized to carry a negative two charge
the tetrahedral intermediate that we
form will collapse kicking out sulfur as
a leaving group remember in this step we
protonated histidine so we can use the
charged imidazole to give sulfur its
proton back
the tetrahedral intermediate collapses
this carbon sulfur bond breaks and this
nitrogen of histidine gets its lone pair
back and we form this bisphosphate that
has high phosphoryl group transfer
ability let's break down the reaction
types we saw throughout this mechanism
overall this is an oxidation but in the
first step we have nucleophilic addition
to a carbonyl since we're losing
electrons from this substrate along the
way that's oxidation remember that our
nad plus is reduced in the process
finally we convert our thioester into
the phosphate that's nucleophilic acyl
substitution
the enzyme that catalyzes step 7 of
glycolysis is phosphoglycerate kinase
this enzyme is actually named for the
reverse reaction
where we'd think about adding a
phosphate group to 3-phosphoglycerate
but we'll look at the reaction in the
glycolysis direction
this reaction in vivo is reversible this
mechanism is nice and straightforward
adp will attack this phosphate
and kick the electrons onto oxygen
and with the transfer of this phosphate
group we form atp the enzyme is
therefore classified as a transferase
and the type of reaction is nucleophilic
substitution when we transfer a
phosphate group to adp
from a compound that has higher
phosphoryl transfer ability
this is called
substrate level phosphorylation
step eight of glycolysis is an
isomerization reaction that will move
this phosphate from the three position
to the two position of the compound
forming two phosphoglycerate from three
phosphoglycerate this reaction has a
really cool mechanism the enzyme
actually contains a
post-translationally modified histidine
that is phosphorylated an active site
glutamate residue deprotonates this
hydrogen the electrons from this bond
attack the phosphate which breaks off of
the histidine temporarily forming an
intermediate with two phosphate groups
to return the enzyme to its active state
the now dephosphorylated histidine will
attack this phosphate group
and our glutamate residue that was
protonated here
can now donate this proton to reform an
alcohol the arrow pushing looks like
this histidine attacks the electrons
from this oxygen phosphorus bond grab
the proton on glutamic acid and the
electrons from the o-h bond become a
lone pair on glutamate this enzyme is
isomerizing
3-phosphoglycerate and is classified as
an isomerase
but to do these phosphate transfers
we're using nucleophilic substitution
reactions
with the phosphate group now at the two
position the enzyme enolase will convert
two phosphoglycerate
into phosphoenol pyruvate
phosphoenolpyruvate has higher
phosphoryl transfer ability than atp so
we're setting ourselves up for another
substrate level phosphorylation by
forming this compound
the name enolase suggests formation of
an enolate
here's a carbonyl and we can form an
enolate adjacent to it the lone pair on
a deprotonated lysine will deprotonate
this hydrogen
and the electrons will move on to the
carbon adjacent to the carbonyl the
enolate that's formed has resonance
stabilization with the carbonyl because
of this resonance stabilization it's
very likely that this anion forms first
and then the oh group is eliminated in
an e1cb reaction
a protonated glutamic acid side chain
donates a proton on this hydroxyl
group's way out the arrow pushing looks
like this with the double bond here and
the o h eliminated we've formed pep the
enzyme is breaking off a molecule of
water so it's classified as a liase and
the reaction type is elimination
very likely e1cb
[Music]
at this point in glycolysis
energetically
two atp have been consumed and two atp
were produced one for each molecule of
bpg
now we'll get our final payoff
when pyruvate kinase catalyzes a second
substrate level phosphorylation
transferring the phosphate from pep
to adp forming atp and pyruvate i'll
show this mechanism in two ways
adp is going to attack this phosphate
and we're going to get shifts of
electrons that end up with protonation
of this ch2
so let's add in a generic acid we'll
begin our arrow pushing on a negatively
charged oxygen of adp attacking this
phosphate notice pyruvate has a ketone
when we break this bond we'll push it to
make that ketone and now the
carbon-carbon double bond can break
becoming protonated that's a lot of
arrow pushing for one step and viewing
the arrow pushing slightly differently
can help us see why pep is such a great
transfer of this phosphate group so
let's just attack the phosphate
and leave a negative charge on this
oxygen instead the compound that will
form showing the attack this way is an
enolate now enols and enolates tend to
tautomerize to their more stable keto
forms so this tautomerization is also
pushing this reaction forward we'll
bring in our generic acid and show the
arrow pushing for our final protonation
from here again we're transferring a
phosphate group
and the enzyme is a transferase because
we're substituting a new phosphate group
onto adp
this reaction type is nucleophilic
substitution
i hope you enjoyed this video and
learned something new for more chemistry
and biochemistry subscribe to my channel